thank you so I'm one of the few that is
not going to present with reveal I've
got slot for a corporation we do
everything by PowerPoint but at least
you'll get to see the big splash a cat
yellow there and the funny part about
this template is you can see our secret
for autonomy up there it's just a simple
fraction 2 to the 5th 7 squared over 4
3rd nobody at all seriousness i'm here
to talk about driving finding driving
style patterns in machine data so first
the background orient you about our
company so we are one of the bigger
manufacturers in illinois listen to
downstate Illinois or headquartered in
Peoria Illinois we've got facilities in
Aurora Decatur Peoria mossville and we
actually power opening a analytics
office right here in Chicago but you may
know of us as a big industrial company
we make very big industrial machines and
we use machine differently than machine
learning this is a real machine right
large mining trucks articulated trucks
excavators motor graders we have a very
vast product line we're actually in the
mining as well we have rope shovels
hydraulic mining shovels underground
mining and very diverse portfolio of
products but what they all have in
common is they use mechanical electrical
hydraulic systems to drive the machine
around to move the implements to do work
to holder to do to dump and all that's
done by the most part a diesel engine
that produces torque produces power and
the power is converted into moving the
machine around so what I show here is
what my talk today is about it's called
the integrated power train system or IPs
for short and integrated power train
systems very complicated architecture
and mechanical system it uses
traditional mechanical things like
direct direct drive or
here the gear shifting like the
converter drive uses an upper powertrain
a lower power train and of course the
engine itself and this just doesn't
happen automatically it's all controlled
by electronics so we have embedded
control software the Colonel's control
software is constantly trying to
optimize along a number of different
variables such like the operators is
giving it inputs like you wants to
accelerate or decelerate who wants to
produce a lot of power and moved or he
also wants to feel comfortable it
doesn't want to be rocking around in the
cab and then on the other hand the
company that is producing the machine
does not want to spend money on fuels
we're trying to economize on fuel we're
trying to burn the fuel cleanly so
there's not emissions so this is all
done with electronics and software
software is very complicated it has maps
that are trying to pick how much fuel
mixture to use they want to be
economical at some point but if you're
too economical you lose power you can't
do your work and move the dirt around so
for for long periods of cats history we
had the electronics we had data flowing
in our machines we weren't making use of
it so enter the new age of data and
telematics maybe about seven years ago
we started putting on data loggers on
the machines that could log data
autonomously and produce or send it back
through the cell network or Wi-Fi or
satellite or whatever the Machine happen
to have you got to remember a lot of
these machines are working in area
without an infrastructure so there are
you know a place to plug in to just push
your data back to the Internet we're
creating that infrastructure so it can
be expensive but we've started moving
more and more data through of these wife
I'd cell phone and satellite
technologies now all that data is time
series data it can come back to
caterpillar we can put it in a
repository and make use of it so what
are we doing with it well I have a video
here i'm going to show just if you
just a one-minute video this was
introduced the spring it's a new
initiative that we have called the age
of smart iron oops so by my miles an age
will connected devices are a breeding
lives shin izing work of job sites to
generators to machines of all sizes this
is the a dryer flexes its intelligence
where the machinery that enriches lives
powers businesses and build communities
given the connectivity to be even safer
more efficient and more productive this
is the a draw industry evolves the eggs
were job sites from their home anglers
where it's higher peaks the same
language where work gets done faster
with your setbacks this is the new era
of smart and can is built forth welcome
to the age of smart I ok so about two
years ago I started meeting with the
integrated power training system and
they said we have this process by which
we have a lot of field data we have
virtual simulation models that we can
drive with field data it's like playback
data you play the data through the model
and it will exercise the control
software and then they can find problems
where it doesn't work real well it
doesn't optimize around fuel
productivity and operator comfort so
when they make changes to the software
they'd like to just be able to go grab a
set of data run it through their model
to show that it's validated it's
actually achieving what they want the
process that was not as optimal as
they'd like it to be they would go
through the data that they had and
manually select some cycles that they
thought were representative of the field
but they never knew I mean are they just
pulling out of a corner of that data set
is if one thing that that operator does
and no no other operatives do so they
said we really want to find a way to go
across
canvass all of our data and pull out a
few patterns not a lot of them but a few
patterns that represent the field and
they have started to do this manually
was way too time-consuming to find
examples of things that were dunnell
very often on the other hand if you
tried to reduce the data and do some
kind of reduction scheme like doing
histograms of certain what we call
channels which are the time series that
doesn't work because for parking systems
it really doesn't matter and what water
things happen what gear with what order
you go through gears whether you're
accelerating or decelerating so the time
dependency matters although those
operations can be time dilated they can
be longer or shorter and it can be time
reordered so I rephrase this problem of
how do i use represent represented data
to validate my software as how do i
automatically find these time series at
scale these patterns first thing i
wanted to get a real clear idea on was
well what kind of patterns are we
talking about and this this was the
explanation they gave me well we're
looking for predominant ones ones that
are the one you know the type of
patterns that happen in this data more
often than not and we don't we can't
actually use a very long pattern because
we're going to drive our simulation
software simulation is a converging
solution takes a long time usually so
you can only take up to about 10 or 15
minutes otherwise that runtime gets long
and of course their patterns were based
on the powertrain features that they
were very interested in like the gear
shifts the speeds the accelerations
torques duration of the operations so
forth but clearly after we got into the
discussion I realize they weren't
looking for exact waveform matches they
were not looking through the data when
does it follow this you know this uh
inclination and so forth of a sine wave
they weren't looking for that they were
looking for specific aggregate features
across the multivariate data but not
exact wave four matches and just a side
note if you're looking for a way to do
wave four matches take a look at dynamic
time warping and symbolic act
approximate aggregation we actually
started down
that path and did it for another project
but for this one it wasn't about
waveform it's about features so how many
patterns were they looking for that was
another thing i asked you looking for a
hundred or five and they said well
probably we don't really know we like
the data to tell us how many patterns
are in there but the best guess is maybe
there's maybe 10 or 20 different
patterns that we care about so let the
data to the side this image i'm showing
you here is the continuous data that was
recorded we're breaking it up into those
10-minute patterns and so it was kind of
important that we realize you don't have
to do a sliding window search that you
could segment the data into ten-minute
segments and each each segment even
though it's artificial where it happens
across a wide enough data set that
doesn't matter we'll just partition the
data so here's our approach I'm going to
go through this kind of in a business
analyst level then I'll show you a
little more of the code behind it so we
start at the top left we have the data
logger time series and for a given
machine model we might have 50,000 hours
80,000 hours something of that nature
we're going to take all this data and
segments into 10 minute windows then
we're going to calculate specific
features related to the power train
system and we need to scale those
because the features are not all on the
same magnitude we don't want one feature
to outweigh the others just based on
scale of it then we run principal
component analysis pca and i'll explain
this later but this is to reduce the
dimensionality of the data and then we
want to limit that dimensionality to the
critical dimensions that really
represent the underlying structure so we
have a rule of thumb just to limit the
dimensions to eighty percent of the date
very data variability then we go through
a loop where we do iterative clustering
we cluster from about five to twenty and
that that range is sort of user
configurable but that's what's worked
for us and each time that we cluster we
use k-means clustering it's pretty basic
data science we're not using all that
advanced algorithms but for each one of
those we calculate a dissimilarity score
which is something that I invented
apparently you there's a couple
different ways you can find the optimal
number of cluster
I haven't researched all of them but
there are some other methods I like to
try in the future so our dissimilarity
score gives us a value just a single
value for that set of K clusters and
then we look at them from 5 to 20 and
pick the optimal one so once we know how
many clusters was the optimal one we can
pull out those centroids and then use
those to predict against the data that
we have and draw five samples and this
could be five it could be three it could
be 10 but enough samples that I can show
the time series windows the sessions and
say here are some examples of each of
those clusters maybe you can find some
introspection and what makes them
similar so a little more detail on each
of those steps feature engineering what
do we mean by going and calculating the
specific power train system features so
I'm not going to show you the ones that
we actually use is a sort of cat
proprietary but this was based on a
journal article in the society of
automotive engineering SAE journal
really where we got a lot of the the
ideas of doing this and this is the list
of their features and if you look
through those there they're just
aggregations on a specific entity like
the time spent at low speed or the time
spent in that window related to maximum
acceleration so this was at the paper
here was actually a classification
problem they were trying to train a
model based on driving highway driving
forces city driving and then see if they
could accurately predict any given set
of time series which that falls into so
different problem but same idea that we
can use features to do an unsupervised
classification supervised learning
application so now we have all this data
and by the way what I just showed you
the feature engineering and the
calculated features that's the hardest
part of this whole process this huge
amount of data takes by far ninety
ninety-five percent of the times maybe
more to get all that data but once you
pull it all that's reduced data it's a
nice rectangular data set maybe a
hundred and fifty to four hundred
thousand rows
and 50 to 60 columns which are your
features right sex like a think of it
like a big Excel spreadsheet so this
fits in main memory very easily now that
I've reduced it but I'm I'm not able to
do the clustering I want across the many
columns because clustering in high
dimensions becomes problematic we like
to reduce those columns so what we do is
we use PCA transformations the wife
oscilla stration because it's a good way
to get insight PCA if you're not heard
about it takes multi-dimensional data
set in this example there's three
dimensions and it finds the first axes
of most of greatest variance it calls
that your first component and then finds
the next axes orthogonal to that that's
second greatest in variance and it kind
of does that until it's completed all
the dimensions so then you can choose to
reduce or drop the dimensions of least
variance like they go from the 3d 3d
geometry to a flattened 2d geometry but
they're kind of retaining the structure
of the data and getting rid of those
higher dimensions so we do that but not
from three to two we do it from like 50
to 60 dimensions down to a as may as you
can count on one hand so again that's
sort of arbitrary but the second plot
here shows how we do that this rule of
thumb about the 80 8020 rule we say how
many of principal components does it
take to get to the eighty-eight percent
of your cumulative variability as
determined by these eigenvalues so for
the example i'm showing here we started
with 54 components and at the eighth
component we had eighty percent of
variability so really all those other
dimensions are just noise I don't really
care about them we'll throw them away
another way to think about what PCA does
is you still have all your features so
this plot shows on the vertical axis all
the features and on the horizontal axis
these are the eighth principle
components we kept but not every feature
has the same importance there's a
waiting there's a what they call look
feature loading that transforms you from
the original data space to the pca data
space so one thing you can do is take
these features in
sort them by like a sum squared value
costs across the row because not one not
not just one coefficient and one column
is the indication important it's really
across the whole columns so you do that
and you kind of see I actually only
about half of the features here but my
eye shows me the ones at the top have
the biggest coefficients the biggest
importance you get down far enough and
they're all getting to be near zero so
you know those lower features if you're
trying to get some insight into what the
dataspace looks like lower features
don't have a big impact on clustering
but the features at the top of this list
would so this is now we take this pca
transform fewer dimension data set and
we do unsupervised learning on it which
using k-means clustering there are some
other algorithms we could be using with
the simplest this shows you the output
of just one of those k values k equals
13 so what do we know at this point well
we know how many observations or how
many 10-minute windows fall into each of
the clusters and they're not even you
can see here there some are more some
are less depending on your data set and
on the right we can get some insight
into where those clusters are being
formed by doing pairwise plots of every
principal component so it's a little bit
hard to see but first row there is the
first principal component second second
row is the second and then the same
thing on the x-axis so you get cross
plots there of one principal component
to the other it's hard when you get too
many components but when there's few you
can say well this region in the
principal component space is cluster one
this other region is poster to so forth
and we'll need that when we when we look
at windows we actually look at sampled
time series and we're going to try to
figure out what are they actually
telling us so final final step to being
able to generate these samples is what
is the optimal cluster number so I came
up with a very just simple statistical
method by which we we take you can see
this plot down on the bottom left we
take every combination of clusters so
cluster 1 2 2 1 2 3 2 2 3 so forth
and we do a student t hypothesis test on
the means of every principle component
what we're looking for is way I describe
this is you know you start with five
clusters the clusters are big they grab
a lot of data there's a lot of variable
variability in that data and so it's
possible that a clustered does doesn't
have enough specificity in it you'd like
to shrink the cluster until it's you
know just just around enough data that
it's unique and as you shrink those
clusters and then become more and more
the borders press in on each other and
now it's very difficult at the edges of
the clusters for those values to be
unique so I was telling myself that
maybe there's this you know convex curve
that there's a peek at so by summing up
all of the t-test that passed divided by
the total we're looking for a number
that's close to one or the greatest
number doesn't really work out that way
when you when you do it on a set of data
you get this kind of noisy line and when
I show here there's like three that are
at the max cluster nine which is nine
clusters 13 clusters and 16 so talking
with the the IPS team I said you know
which one do you want to go with here
and they said well fewer is probably
better up to a certain point because we
have to run simulation on every one of
these clusters you provide us but too
few and then we don't know we're not
seeing enough of the detail those
clusters it might be too general so we
went for the middle we pick 13 this is
one of the weak parts of the process
that we hope to improve so here's the
implementation and we are using Python
this is PI data so we'll start with the
data stores and the files and we use
hdf5 files which is a hierarchical data
format this these files are great for
our type of data is when we're not using
we don't have textual data this is
numeric its binary it's very large and
what hdf5 does well is compress that
data they have a chunking compression
algorithm for our data it saves ninety
percent of the data on disk and then
actually reads off a disk faster because
you read the compress
chunk and then you get your CPU which is
faster than disk can decompress that in
memory faster than you could read the
you know raw data so hdf5 is great it
also provides a hierarchical storage
model so we can actually stored things
at different places within the data and
it stores metadata along with the data
so we save things like units of sensor
values of the scaling values we have
what the software part number might have
been at the time the data was recorded
now so if you wanted to do this with
don't ever use CSV for this kind of data
I mean it would just be huge and it
wouldn't be able to store the data as
efficiently so in by the way hdf group
is the nonprofit organization that
supports hdf5 they are located in
champaign illinois actually so they're
very close to us there's some folks from
hdf group here today i recommend you
talk to them if you're interested about
their product hdf5 by the way is open
source and it's got bindings in every
language python being one of them the
module we use is h 5 pi it's very it's
very performant it just wraps some see
libraries so does everything for us that
we want but the challenge we had with
operating on the hdf5 files was the way
the files are saved is sort of arbitrary
arbitrary it buffers the data it saves
it maybe every hour and so when we take
slots of data we might fall on an
interval between two files if we ask for
a very wide interval we might grab more
than one file so we wrote a did access
layer which actually abstracts that and
all we do is give it the data range that
we want and it goes off finds the files
that that is satisfied by and reads it
into memory so challenges around using
hdf5 are so you've got all these files
you've got all this data in the files
but you don't if you're running them on
a file system you don't have a way to
know what's in the file until you open
them and that can be very costly so we
needed it we've had to implement an
indexing service that can read some of
the metadata put it in a storage
solution that can retrieve that
information very quickly io scalability
now
that I'm reading on a disk these many
files I can only read so much data in
one process so I'd like to go
multi-process I'd like to do multi note
if I can and that's a scalability issue
and then cloud storage finally as we go
into the cloud hdf5 is a binary format
it requires POSIX compliance and the
file systems and the cloud storage
providers don't have this as of yet
where it's very expensive so we're
trying to find a solution and the HTF
group is working on that as well so now
we've read the data into memory for a
given session of data you know a
10-minute window at this point it's just
conventional scientific computing this
is the stuff that we've been doing in
Python for years you just have a data
set that's finite and we need to go
compute things that probably couldn't be
done in an embarrassingly parallel way
like a filter the data and a forwards
backwards way I'm an example that here
or do event detection where we're
actually looking through the data to
find maybe when something happened like
a gear shift so there's great libraries
for this we use numpy sipe i especially
the signal processing module and then
pandas makes the things that are boolean
related very easy for doing split apply
combined type of workflows so the two
examples I show here are this one's a
pure boolean feature when when channel
one does not fall in this list of
negative 107 when channel 2 is greater
than a threshold when channel 3 is
greater than zero we take all those
booleans we amp them together we sum
them up count how many data points in
the window is this true as a percentage
of time one on the right is a signal
processing example so we have a faceless
exponential averaging filter the smooths
the data and smooths it in a way that
sort of pays more attention to the long
trends rather than the shore noisy
trends and we do this in the fat forward
backwards way Phil Phil tis a the for
backwards filter so it doesn't induce a
phase shift which is important so we do
that inside of one work one process one
worker for that window
and we can produce the feature and put
it in the feature vector one thing I'll
mention is the cpu uh bottlenecks were
really not thought to be a problem we
were I 0 vam took more time to load the
data but once we scaled this thing out I
found that the naive code I was writing
actually was starting to be the bigger
part of the process it was taking about
75% of my time to calculate these
features I went back in rewrote the
feature code to be more performant and
reused variables and found that then I
got a good balance i was maybe spending
one third of my time when I oh and two
thirds time on cpu so distributed
computing now we're talking about how do
we scale this up we use celery maybe a
bit of a strange choice but i will i'll
say that when we propose the project
there was the thought that we would make
this into a back-end for a web
application that non coders could use
they could just fill out a form it hit a
click go and it would go and submit a
job and get it back so celery is very
good for that it's used in production
environments its robust scalable you
just add nodes you can add and remove
very fault-tolerant it's not super
flexible to changing code it really
wants static code when you start your
cluster and that code shouldn't change
so that's been a bit of a challenge to
think through example on the right here
is one that I ran that was only three
nodes but you can see we got parallelism
each note had four cores and we did
about 150,000 windows of 10-minute
window each this process would have
taken 48 hours on a single process
single node but because we paralyzed it
12 12 X it took four hours and this this
process is scalable so as we go into the
cloud we can add you know 32 nodes and
the time just shrinks till we get two
minutes so a workflow in general is we
take it we have a generator that feeds
these windows session arguments on what
the data needs to be read for for each
window these out to the celery q that's
sequential kinsella asynchronous that
processes all of our tasks in parallel
and internally that feature eyes code I
showed you that's done you
a functional programming pipeline shall
show you in next slide so I'm filing all
those workers send their data back to
the driving process the results are
brought in and we then can do the data
science the filtering out the bad
sessions vectorizing the data you see a
transforming clustering and finally
generating the report so PI tools and
side tools we do use these to make our
life easier inside of a worker we've got
a lot of steps we go through there's a
lot of funny things in the data that can
happen sensors can can drop out go back
go back far up in history and our schema
might have evolved we may have not had a
channel back far enough that that we
added later so in this workflow as I
show here we've got a decorator
basically anytime an air is found we can
not not aboard it but past results the
basic says I don't have any data I'm
empty and it kind of a just flows
through the process without kind of
breaking the code and then we string all
these together all these functions in a
pie tools compose way that just
basically creates one function that we
map against each of the windows so I
highly recommend you look into PI tools
if you're trying to build a pipeline of
custom functions PC a transformation
this is the easy part easy relatively
we've got good libraries for that sike
it learns got a PCA class we just call
that on it you get the results back and
then you can look at the explained
variance ratio do a cumulative sum and
find that point of which you're right
just beyond 80% k-means clustering this
is a this is another drop in from the
module scikit-learn you just call
k-means and do your fit on it one chance
I will mention is K means it's really
not clustering even though it's called
that it's partitioning it's your data
space and it tries to create like sort
of equal regions of space in the data so
if you really want true clustering like
based on density you'll look at a
different method and of course choosing
an optimal number of clusters that's
sort of an art not a science
so here's my example results let me just
orient you to what this is this is a we
pulled out for a given cluster cluster
one there's the vertical lines d market
where the windows begin and then so
there's 55 sample windows and these
would have come from different machines
in different geographic locations
different operators and so forth but the
same machine so here's cluster one and
then here's I when there's 13 of them I
can't show you all of them because it'd
be too too small but here's four of them
and your I can sometimes pick up pick up
on what the trend is like I see on this
top left one there's a lot more
variability in these two curves but in
the middle but sometimes you'll say well
what is the difference between these
these two sample clusters and I feel
like they look visually the same it
turns out when you look into the details
of what features were clustered there
are indeed differences so for these for
the domain expert kind of reviewed the
day and said well I see here is a trend
of top one is in high gear and slowing
down top right is in neutral it's
waiting in the line backing up bottom
one is minik you're traveling and doing
hard work and then the final one would
be mid geared slowing down so they
confirm that this indeed is finding
patterns in the data at least at a
comprehensible level here's another
example and large mining trucks I think
we found 10 clusters I'm i can show 9
funny thing we usually do see in the top
middle plot there we usually find a
cluster that's idle I mean data is flat
all the features are kind of near zero
or whatever we're calculating so you do
hope to find that you hope that the
idols not spread out in other clusters
or that would be an indication it's not
working wheel loader again there's like
top right is sort of the idle state some
of these you can see visually this one's
got some half activity half idle there's
some lots of slow-moving activity and
then there's a few clusters of high
frequency movement and whatever features
they clustered around they are in fact
different track type tractor this one
was interesting because
at this I had a lot of channels for this
one a lot of time series plot so I can
actually show you only show you uh I
think this is about 10 in the first plot
and it the first one I looked at these I
thought wow there's a lot of this stuff
actually looks the same but when you
look at the second set of channels and
second plots and you get to look at the
combination of them right so they might
look the same in one series of plots
they might look different another or
it's really the joint between all of
them that they find the clusters really
though to get the inside of what's
different what I find is we're always
going back to this PC a pairwise plot
this is really this is my favorite plot
because when you look into this data
space you can find the region that the
data is centralized around one
difficulty of the this is using Seaborn
I believe when difficulty is it plots
the data in a way where the first
clusters are plotted and then it plots
second set of data and then the third so
it's the last clusters that are most
visible and the ones that are plotted
first so in this one and be the light
blue it's actually kind of obscured so
what I found in its necessary if you're
really trying to distinguish two
clusters is just plot those two clusters
in the pairwise fly then they won't be
obscured by other clusters another thing
you can do is get out of the pairwise
domain and look at just the raw
principal component of values the
distribution as a histogram sometimes
you'll see like oh it's uh whoops the
back up here you know it's hit or miss
but you'll say maybe a one principal
component is definitely at the low end
of that prints for that cluster in this
other clusters at the high end so
another way is just review the data in
this space can help and then finally we
can go back and look at histograms of
the actual features so this was a
feature I grabbed and you'll notice that
my cluster for all of the values our way
on the high end and cluster 7 all the
values with the high end all the other
features have a lot of day on the low
end of that range for the feature so but
this is this really mean think about it
we're not clustering at the future level
we r plus Turing at the p
principal component level so you get a
mixed bag of whether this is really
helpful to look at an individual feature
and then finally this was always saying
earlier this was a data set with smaller
principal components needed only for but
you see that that overlapping problems
happening so what I show here is ok
plotting just two plotting three
different clusters and it becomes much
more evident yes the club the clusters
are separated in the principal component
space and what I found with our data is
it's very globular in the principal
component space it's not spread out or
islands of data for the most part here's
an exception we're like the purple
cluster is very much on its owns like a
peninsula sticking out on the data space
so in conclusion what worked well and
what needs improvement I'll say that the
team has been very impressed they say we
are producing believable patterns useful
patterns and they can introspect what
those cluster identities are using
visualization we found a way to scale
the problem up doing parallel
computation on celery and clean
functional programming pipeline that
makes rationalizing about the code very
easy what needs improvement so over time
we had to run this many times we would
find errors in the future code for
example when you say when throttles at 0
your that's you know call out it call
that a percent of time that you're at
zero turns out when the guy is at zero
in the cab the signal might be at point
zero one so we have to go run a whole
job and find out that the feature needs
a little margin change the margin rerun
it and then improve so doing that over
again and over again we found that we
needed a better workflow management and
way to way to compare results 1 versus
the next iteration celery can be a
little rigid as I mentioned so if i
define my future's right now and try to
run them and the cluster is already
running you'd have to stop the closer
and restart it although i found a way to
hack it so that you could serialize the
function and get it to load that on
demand and then it's a bit core
we had a few things go wrong that we've
changed the code and then it worked and
then the last thing is we might
investigate a better clustering method
so k-means is great for partitioning the
space but if we want to actually look at
where the dense density of the data is
we're looking at hdb scan which is a
very good recommended algorithm and then
maybe or what multivariate stats are
better used for finding that optimal
number here's my last slide recognition
and this was a team effort we had
Michael Anderson and the IPS core group
giving us their domain expertise these
guys are not coders but they know what
they want out of the data co-development
team i had que si Jin and Sanjeev
armagon help me and data science and I'm
a mechanical engineer background but I
am a developer so i got my mentoring
from saying Kim and then finally we had
some guys very good at the distributed
computing on Cordy Danya and david
viaero who are actually here today so
great team effort we're really happy the
way this worked out and with that I'll
take questions does feature in any
require domain expertise yes it does
although i think they struggle sometimes
on one of the best features to have and
you know initially I got a laundry list
of features like here's 500 features we
want I said well are these really unique
so we would work through you want these
specific features out of your data maybe
we can combine some maybe we can make
rather than like count every time add
value is different in the channel maybe
find regions of that channel which are
actually more functionally important so
yes I I can it help it took someone like
me I guess to kind of talk with them
about the mechanical engineering and
about their systems but then be able to
translate that to code so I would say
yes yep
so again
transform base features you may like FFT
oh yeah okay um so like frequency based
method spectral based methods those are
you see those use a lot when you don't
have an idea what you want out of the
signal you're not looking for events
that happen or you're not looking for
not waveform features but maybe my
percentage of time that this value is
across a threshold if you just get the
data and your data scientist you're not
you're not knowledgeable about the data
I would probably go the way of doing
spectral methods because that does tell
you things about the wave like the low
frequency trends and a high frequency
trends I'll give an example there was a
cattle competition on brain wave data
also time series and you know they put
that as a contest the winner actually
used I think there's like 20 different
features and a lot of them were either
signal processing or spectral based so I
mean I that's probably what I would do
if I didn't know what I was looking for
in the data thank you yes for prediction
is there anything that we're trying to
predict so this was an unsupervised
problems with trying to find structure
in the data but after we've solved that
they have started talking about okay
does this change over time like if I
cluster the data today or in this
geographic location do i do I see data
coming in it looks different and that
would be an inversion of the problem
that would be a classification problem
I've got some ideas you could take the
centroids that you get out of this and
then classify your incoming observations
to see you know are the distribution of
the counts of those classes staying the
same or is one going up are you getting
if you use a density based method you
could say am I getting a new region in
the dataspace that's never existed
before so I think that would be a way to
make it predicted yes
okay right so how long did the project
run from start to finish and second part
was how what is it being used for the
value at the practical okay so we
started maybe talking three years ago
and actually the hardest one of the
hardest part of the project was really
define the problem took about a year to
figure out that they really wanted
unsupervised classification because the
way they've been doing it was we're
finding cycles in the data it starts at
this location geographically in the mind
it goes to this location and they would
pull it out and so look more like a
supervised classification problem that
the more we kind of worked on that they
kept being told no it's not really what
we want we want we want you to tell us
what the structure of the data is
actually looking like so it took a year
to work through just conversations on
what they were looking for and then
divided to devise an actual and a
workflow that would work then it took
another year to write the first version
of co which was very sloppy off to say
because we didn't know what things were
going to change and what things would
need to say the same we weren't really
building it for scale either sort of a
research project and then in the third
year of the project was converting it
into like a production model that we can
run with robustness and scale it to
different features because it was really
tight around the features of the first
prototype right and then the practical
application back to the very beginning I
talked about software validation so they
are hoping to I don't think they've
quite done this yet but take those
samples and drive their simulation
models to show that there there's no
corner cases or failure modes if they
didn't anticipate so control validation
software validations one but they're
starting to get these side insights that
weren't expected either so because
they're able to see samples of the data
and they're told that hey there's this
many cluster there's this many window
counts in your data they can say oh in
South America my large mining trucks
never used a high gear I didn't know
that I wonder why that is and then they
can go into the day of maybe try to come
up with a hypothesis related that um
other insights are that the data isn't
what we want it to be like I said about
not throttles a nonzero
oh it's a sort of almost zero or that
maybe we're not recording some of the
channels that we need to for the study
so it's just scalability and
visualization on the data has been
really big on opening our eyes into what
we want to do with the data and what we
need to improve thank you in the back
last question
sure so which I repeat are we
partitioning it to look for you said
maybe by temperature region geograph 8
age of the machine to see if we can find
some some comparisons that this area is
very different than this is other area
and I'd say yes to some extent we
haven't fully explored that area but the
two we were most interested in was
geographic location so are our machines
in this area running very differently in
this other area and there's a challenge
that for that because you can either
cluster them separately and get a good
idea of what patterns are unique to one
area versus the other but they're not
kind of comparable because the way
k-means work or you can cluster them all
together in which case you kind of get a
uniform view of what clusters are occur
on all those location and then you can
pull out the count or geographic
location another one they want to do is
we have we released software updates and
they would like to know with this
software update was the performance of
the machine different than after the
software update was made we have a
looked at temperature or climate
conditions no soil conditions but I
think that would be in the future as
well they're mostly seeing that they
could do by customer if they had more
side data right if we could get data on
well this these machines are running in
this industry or these machines are
running under this dealer area are they
getting different behaviors based on
that so if this enables a huge amount of
further study that hasn't been explored
thank you we don't thank you